hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be going over how to attack the Nachman
sin game it if your opponent decides to
decline the line and not partake in all
the fun that is the accepted line so the
Nachman sin game it if you are not
familiar a lot of ways that you can get
to it but many times it's going to be
from the Italian game be 45 not f3
knight c6 Bishop to c4 they respond with
Knight to f6 White's just looking to
develop material here the d4 after they
take White's not done giving up material
castle on the King side giving up the
other central pawn not generally
something you want to do unless you have
a very good reason for it but why it's
not done and that is Knight to c3 this
is the neck mincing game it I've done
two other videos on the neck mincing
gambit one is if black takes with the
pawn here the other one is if the knight
takes here on c3 but in today's video
we're gonna be going over what happens
if black declines this gambit here on c3
I am trying something new in this video
in the description below I will have
links to each of the variations of how
black can defend I know a lot of you
come back to these videos and you may
just want to see hey my I'm seeing my
opponent playing this one variation and
instead of just fast-forwarding through
the video I'm gonna have links below so
you can go to those individual lines the
particular lines we are going to be
going over in this video the first one
is Knight to d6 makes a lot of sense
this does protect the knight also
defends the square here on f7 and
attacks this Bishop here on c4 the next
one is Knight to f6 then we're gonna be
looking at Bishop to e7 as well as pawns
who d5 so again links below if you want
to fast forward at any point to any of
those moves if you would also please
like this video if you haven't already
please subscribe definitely helps out
the channel putting in a lot of work
into these videos I've had a lot of
requests to go deeper into the openings
not just do a high-level so try that out
with enactments in game but this is the
third in-depth video for the night
and game it so if you wouldn't mind
please like in the video that definitely
helps a lot so let's go ahead and get
into it and the first variation we're
gonna be looking at is if black declines
by playing Knight to d6 now a common
theme that we're gonna have throughout
this video is you always need to be
attacking in the Nachman sin gamut it's
not good enough to find moves where you
allow your opponent to exchange material
you trade off your queen all of a sudden
you're down material you're in the
middle approaching the endgame and
there's just no way for you to win so
you always want to be attacking your
opponent the best way to continue the
attack here is Bishop to g5 now there's
a couple ways they could defend this
Bishop to e7 makes a lot of sense they
could also play Knight to e7 but Bishop
d7 seems pretty straightforward from
black this is being protected by the
Queen and the Knights also it prepares
to castle on the Kings side why it's
going to continue to take this material
here on e7 now more than likely they're
gonna go ahead and take with their
knight they could take with their queen
but it gets kind of awkward once you
play rook here to e1 at some point so
Knight to e7 and then Queen to d4 want
to be extremely aggressive in this game
and this is the best way to do that
attacking right here on g7 now they have
a couple options if part of how they can
continue they can castle on the King
side or they could play Knight takes
here on c4 first let's go ahead and take
a look at if they castle on the King
side we want to keep our Bishop very
involved into the game and once you
castle on the King side your Kings
pretty safe and this f7 Square is pretty
safe as well before you castle this is a
vulnerability because usually the king
is the only piece that's protecting it
in this case the night here on d6 is
protecting it as well another reason
that this Bishop on this long light
square diagonal isn't doing as much so
castle on the King side best move for
white to continue as Bishop to d3 and
this is attacking a very vulnerable
Square here on Age seven so if blacks
not paying attention you know an extreme
example would be H a six here they're
probably not going to but to give you an
example of how this would look
Bishop to h7 and Black's gonna have a
difficult time it
they take here it's actually going to be
a loss that there's no way to stop the
the threat although it does take a while
from here because Knight to g5 this is
threatening Queen up here to h7 and then
blacks just gonna lose so much material
here there there's no way to stop it
now it could take awhile depending on if
your opponent plays correctly but there
is no way to stop the the threat at some
point now if we come back if they don't
take that that Bishop there on h7 that's
gonna be completely fine still going to
be a very very good game for whites but
they could say King to h8 okay well now
still Queen to h4 this is threatening a
discovered attack once the bishop moves
here they could decide to play Knight to
f5 this is attacking the Queen is it is
defended by the Knights right here but
again remember that discovered attack
here you can't just take this Bishop
back with the Knights here this is check
really need to take with the Queen here
after the Queen takes then the bishops
are you have the knight taking here on
h4 this is protecting this Bishop white
is up a material here with a very very
strong attack going on the King's no
longer as safe and it's in the corner
which as we get into the middle game you
want to get your King involved into the
action it's not right now so why it's
gonna have a very very good game in this
position now let's come back you're
probably not gonna see a 6 but some of
the other options Bishop to d3 and then
g6
okay well this stops the immediate
threat of the Bishop coming here to h7
from here why it's gonna get more
material involved into the game rook
here to e1 this is more threats that
you're putting on your opponent because
it may look like this night here on e7
is safe
the Queen is protecting it so right now
may want to try to get the lights for a
bit involvement of the game can't
because of this pawn here on the D file
it's not going anywhere so could decide
to play b6 preparing for Bishop here to
b7 but Y can actually just take this
material here on e7 because after the
Queen takes then Knight to d5 attacking
the Queen there's no real good square
for
the night to go tour the Queen to go to
here but maybe Queen comes back here to
d8 and then Knight to f6 check King to
h8 and then Knight to g5 there's always
gonna be a discovered attack with this
Knight if it moves and it's protected so
the Queen can't just take it here is
protected by the Queen so a lot of
attacking lines that White has its
position should end up with a very very
easy game you can also just take here at
age 7 is protected by the knight here as
well so let's come back maybe they don't
play g6 maybe another option would be
okay let's let's bring our Knights here
to f5 this opens up the door for the
pond to come at some point this is also
attacking the Queen right here why can
just swing over to g4 being extremely
aggressive here does not want to just
retreat the Queen
so maybe d5 at this point and then rook
over here to e1 you still want to
continue all of your attacking lines in
this position so if we come back to this
position right here we just looked at if
what if black castles on the King set
but they could also take with their
nights here on c4 now what you shouldn't
do is just take with your queen right
here on c4 because then they're going to
castle on the King side and you don't
have any more threats black is up upon a
material pretty safe spot right here at
the end of day it's gonna be difficult
to get that material back and you've
lost all your attacking pieces better
would be to just go ahead and start
gobbling up material here Queen or after
they play Knight takes here on t4 Queen
to g7 and this puts more pressure on
your opponent because they may not
understand this position all too well
and they may not recognize that f8 is
actually a huge mistake g8 they may look
at that and say yeah just you're just
gonna gobble up my material here on age
7 so there's no difference in g8 or f8
and so they may think that f8 is
actually a safer move but it's not
because after f8 well this is going to
lose too
Knight to g5 putting a lot of pressure
on the opponents right here and then how
do they really respond in this position
maybe opening up for their King to move
maybe d5 here but then Knight 2h7
this is threatening the Queen coming
here to f8 maybe Knight to f6 or f5
because this is also threatening the
knight coming here to f6 so that's gonna
be made by itself so maybe then we have
Knight to f5
Queen takes here on f8 and you can just
see material starts to gobble up there's
just no good way for black to continue
in this spot now if we come back and say
yeah that's what happens if the rook
comes to f8 what if it does come to g8
okay understand just go ahead and gobble
up material here this King is not gonna
be safe the rest of the game and so
while they are up material here it is
definitely going to be difficult for
them to win this game White's just gonna
be attacking the rest of the way and it
also allows for other areas for them to
make mistakes because this rook is being
protected but what if they think they're
safe right now and they play Knight
takes on b2 they want to gobble up
material right here well this is going
to lose to Knight to e5 this is
threatening Queen coming here to f7 so
how do they really stop that maybe at
this point rook to f8 but then Knight to
g4 and this is again going to lose
because it's threatening this Knight to
f6 same as we saw before
maybe Knight to g6 trying to stop that
but then a rook over here to e1 Queen to
e7 Knight to d5 you can see things are
getting worse and worse for black now
let's come back in this position maybe
they don't take that material they're on
b2 maybe they play d5 this is protecting
this night here on c4 this is opening up
for the lights where a bishop to get
involved into the game okay we're gonna
bring our rook over here to e1 continue
to attack maybe they play Bishop to c6
and then rook to d1 continuously giving
them opportunities to make a mistake now
the best move for black
this position is actually King to d7 but
this is an incredibly difficult move to
find for black how many people once the
rook comes over to the D file are gonna
say I'll go ahead and move my King
voluntarily and I'm gonna go ahead and
put it here on this d7 square many of
them are not it's a very very difficult
move to find so let's say in this
position they don't find that move and
they played Knight to be - looks like
it's gobbling up material also it's
hacking this rook here on d1 this works
not really gonna take this material here
on a defy but what white can do is
actually take the material and if the
knight takes here then the rook can
swing up check and after the pawn takes
then the Queen takes here on a g8 and
this is why the King coming here to d7
was such a good move is you don't have
to worry about this move right here of
taking the rook in it being checked but
it's so difficult for black to
understand that that's where they should
go from here King moves to e7 Queen to a
g7 check and then you could see the
knight coming up here - to e4 putting a
lot of pressure on the opponent maybe
now Queen to d7 attacking but then you
just take this material here on b2 now
how do they really continue from here
because it's difficult white is
threatening this material here on b7
but they can still make mistakes so
again you're usually playing this in
some sort of blitz or rapid game if they
look at this and say I'll go ahead and
protect that material let's say b6 here
well then Queen to h8 check and then
they're going to drop even more material
in the game so as we come back here
that's why it's so important that you
continue to attack your opponent once
they take with their night here on C's 4
you can't just take here on c4 you've
lost all your attacking momentum you've
got to continue to continue attacking
and that means you're gonna be playing
Queen to g7 let's come back to this
position right here we just looked at
the bishop comes to e7 but the another
option would be the knight coming here
to
isse Evan now this is starting to block
off the material it's very difficult for
black to continue development this spot
but in this case I'm gonna go ahead and
play Queen takes on d4 no need to
exchange material right here this night
all it is is being pinned down and
blocking the development here so in this
spot how does black really continue well
night taking here on c4 makes a lot of
sense but then we're just gonna play
rook to e1 here and this is where things
you just continue to attack if they say
okay I'm just gonna bring my knight back
here to d6 well now white can take and
they can't take with their Bishop it is
going to be checkmate Queen takes here
on a g7 we can already see here that
they can't play rook to a g8 well that's
going to be checkmate right away and
they also can't just bring their Rick
over here to F a that's going to
eventually lose with Knight to d5 this
is threatening the move Knight to f6
checkmates so let's say maybe they play
Knight to e4 this is stopping the move
right away so rook takes here on e4 pawn
to f5 just trying to stop something but
now all of a sudden rook can come to e7
Queen takes and then this is going to be
checkmate so there's no way to stop that
instead of taking with their Bishop
though you can see if they take with
their Queen well the work and just take
right here on e7 but white actually has
it an even better move and that is the
knight coming here to d5 now if they
wanted to take with their queen that's
fine this is gonna be checking after the
King moves here to d8 then white can
come over here to h4 continue the attack
here pawn to f6 that's fine we can just
take with our Knight right here and they
can't just freely take because this is
going to be checkmate they can just stop
it here and we just recapture so instead
maybe they play Bishop here to e7 but we
just take with our rook right here
maybe Knight to f5 attacking our rook
but that's fine we could just play Queen
to g5
the main theme here is they can't just
freely take with their King because
Knight to d5 check maybe if they want to
continue down this same path
check again we are forking their rook
right here
material is gonna fall here they're
gonna lose their Knights they could lose
you know depending on where they end up
going our Queen can get buried in balm
to the game Queen here to D to continue
the checking we're also threatening our
queen up here to g7 so a lot of
different threats that White has in this
position now if we come back here we
just looked at night coming to d6 let's
say they tried to gobble up material
again that's not what the games about
they need to be focusing on protecting
but same thing Bishop takes here on e7
that they can't just take with their
their material and not end up losing
here Bishop takes on e7 we're gonna have
the Queen coming up here rook to f8
Knight to d5 and this is going to end up
in a checkmate now in this position they
could say well let's play d6 this is
does delay the inevitable here but Queen
takes on h8 maybe King to d6
Queen to h7 you can see White's just
gobbling up all the material here c6
gobble up here on f7 that's not going to
go well either now if we come back
instead of the night taking here on b2
maybe they play d6 but in this case
we're still pinning down there knight in
two different ways both with our rook
and our Bishop here they're not gonna do
anything with this Queen or this night
here on c5 c4 excuse me the Queen can
just freely take that night here on c4
so that's not going to be good so they
could play d5 this does protect this
night here on c4 but that's fine
we are just going to play Bishop takes
after the Bishop takes then the knight
comes up here captures material here
maybe Bishop here to e6 and then the
Queen takes here on g7 rook to f8 and
then Knight to f4 you want to continue
to attack material you can get your
other night involved in
the action if you want to but now you
have the night and of the rook here you
can also swing your rook over at some
point you can gobble a material here on
eight seven how but you have a very very
strong attack other thing you could see
some people always like in the neck
dancing game it to be playing something
like c6 this is not going to help though
Bishop takes here after the bishop takes
Queen takes on g7 you're always gonna be
looking to attack this King side of the
board here rook to f8 and the Knight to
e4 threatening a lot of the same threats
that we had before the next version we
are gonna look at is that the knight
comes back to f6 and in this spot why
it's gonna continue the attack with
Knight to g5 this Knight can freely come
here because it's not being attacked by
the Queen here and this is the way to go
instead of bringing your Bishop here
because instead of bringing your Bishop
and pinning down this Knight this has
two attackers on the square here on f7
pretty common way for white to attack
especially early on this f7 square only
defended by the King
so in this spot how does black continue
if they're not familiar with this that
they could say Knight to e5 this is a
safe Square and it defends the square
here on f7 they may not know of another
option here but that's going to lose
with rook to e1 how do they really stop
this if they now look at and say d5 okay
well then we could just gobble up this
material here on e5 definitely not gonna
be able to stop that now if they come
back and say what if we just play d5 in
this spot okay well that's gonna take
here on d5 if they take then Queen to f3
and we continue the attack a lot of
attacking lines here this is also queen
and the bishop are both attacking this
Knight right here can swing your rook
over here to e1 a pretty common setup
the white has with the night here on g5
the next variation we're gonna look at
is it the bishop comes to e7 looks like
it's blocking a lot of stuff off getting
ready to castle on the King side as soon
as you Castle you feel like you have
safety but we're not gonna allow that to
happen because we're gonna go ahead and
sacrifice material here hey we were all
ready to give up this night here on c3
so what does it matter if we just give
up a bishop here on f7 that's exactly
what we're gonna do after the king takes
right here then the knight comes to e4
don't even have to give up that material
here on a c3 and all of a sudden the
king is open xposed in the game can
really start to attack our opponents now
how do they continue more than likely
they should be playing d5 if they don't
it is gonna be a mistake and you can
start to gobble up more material here
but d5 definitely that the best way to
continue I recommend playing g5 at this
bot I've seen others that will play this
g5 but I just feel like Knight to g5 is
the better option here allows you to
play rook to e1 as your next move
because more than likely they're gonna
be playing either Bishop takes or
they're gonna be bringing their King
back let's say to e8 and then you're
playing rook to e1 pinning down this
material if they do take it's still fine
you're just gonna recapture with your
knight right here it's being protected
by your bishop then you're gonna swing
your rook over you can start to gobble
material at some points but definitely
have a very very good attacking line
with their King completely exposed the
rest of the game the laceration we're
gonna look at is if they play d5 this
puts a lot of pressure on the center and
says yeah we're gonna attack both your
knight and your bishop and we don't want
you attacking our King side of the board
from here I'm gonna completely ignore
that altogether yes you can start to
gobble up this material I just feel like
playing rook to e1 gives my opponent
more opportunities to make a mistake so
from here they have a few options of how
they could continue because they could
always make a mistake they could look at
this and say centers of the board's fine
so I'm gonna play something like Bishop
to g4 I'm gonna go ahead and pin down
more material here and it may look like
this is the way to go but it's actually
not because from here you could just
play Knight takes on d5 and this is
threatening the rook now coming up here
to e4 so from here let's say they played
Knight to e7 then we just gobble up
material right here maybe now they feel
like they need to reach
Bishop to e6 you can just gobble up that
material as well because Knight to f4 is
completely deadly for white now if we
come back and say what if they don't
play 97 what if they just start to
gobble up material right here that's fun
you could just play Queen takes here on
f3 maybe Bishop to e7 Queen takes here
on e4 White has just all the attacking
lines right here now if they look at
this and say okay well that's fine I'm
gonna go ahead and hold on to material
with f5 you can see that the King safety
is just falling by the wayside here and
then h3 is very difficult to deal with
because if the bishop takes they may
feel like they're exchanging material
because they may assume we're gonna
recapture with our queen but we're not
we're gonna recapture with our pawn here
and this Knight can't move it's pinned
down by the rook here on e1 so this
night is going to fall now if the bishop
comes back maybe Bishop to h5 then
Knight to f4 this opens up for the
bishop to come to attack here on f7 but
also attacking the bishop how does the
bishop really respond here maybe Bishop
to G's six
but then Knight to e6 is so difficult to
deal with here it's attacking the Queen
attacking so many critical squares just
no good place for black to really
respond here can get it under not
involved into the game it should be the
bottom to the game it still can't move
the knight because it's being pinned
down if he ever does move it there's
some really really bad places that they
can go to so this is how you respond if
they make a mistake playing Bishop to g4
early on they may not make a mistake so
if they take one of your pieces early on
so they have the option of taking with
the pawn here on c3 they could also take
the bishop here if they take with their
pawn right here I'm gonna go ahead and
recommend and take with your Bishop
right here because you're setting up for
the rook to take here on e4 now if they
try to hold on to this material Bishop
to f5 makes a lot of sense I'm still
gonna take material Bishop takes and
then the bishops gonna capture right
here and the main reason for this is
they may feel like that
can just go ahead and take with their
queen here on d1 but that's actually
gonna be a mistake because we can now
play Bishop to c6 check and they're
gonna have to respond to that
so King to d8 but now we can just come
over here take a material rook takes on
d1 check they now have to move and now
we can bring our bishop here to a4 and
now we are up material so they have to
be careful they really need to take with
their Bishop and after they take with
their Bishop now we can capture with our
rook we do have Czech Bishop to e7 and
then Queen to e2 continued our attack we
don't want to trade off Queens in this
position so if we come back maybe they
don't come with down with their their
Bishop to f5 maybe they play pawn down
to f5 and this spot same thing as we've
seen before and that is Knight up here
to g5 this is not only putting two
attackers on this f7 square it's also
putting another attacker on this efore
square and this knight cannot move it's
still being pinned down by this rook
here on e one now lastly you could see
after this move you could see Bishop
here to e7 in this case we're just going
to take that metal right here if they're
not going to protect it we're definitely
going to take it because it's still
gonna put more pressure on our opponent
if they want to castle on the King side
that's fine we can still continue our
attack the last version we're gonna look
at is in this position if they decide to
take with their pawn here on c4 and you
can already tell our move it's pretty
obvious and that's just taking with our
rook here on e4 check usually you're
gonna see Bishop here to e7 makes a lot
of logical sense for the reasons we've
talked about before preparing a castle
on the King side and the spot you're
gonna be playing Knight takes here on d4
now what's really good is this bey feel
like they can just castle on the King
side no problem at all but this is
actually going to be very very good for
white that's why I like putting my
opponent in positions where they can
make a mistake because this feels pretty
normal but now I can just take with my
night here on c6 now they could feel
like yeah I'll just go ahead and take
with my Queen down here but I can
respond take with my knight here on D 1
and their Bishop is
being attacked right here so if they
move their their queen or their bishop
that's fine if they take with their pawn
well then I could just take their bishop
there up upon a material here but then
you can look at that we have two minor
pieces to their one we're just gonna
gobble up all these pawns right here
they have no good way to continue so in
this spots maybe they play Bishop to f6
but then we play Knight to e7 check then
with gobble up material here we have two
minor pieces to there one we're gonna
start gobbling up material this is not
gonna go well for them so if we come
back here maybe in earlier spots maybe
they don't play Bishop to e7 maybe they
play Bishop to e6 well from here we're
just going to continue with Knight
taking here on d4 attacking this Bishop
we have so many attacking lines we can
get our dark square Bishop been involved
into the game so these are the ways that
I would attack my opponent if they
decline the Nachman sin gambit hopefully
you guys enjoyed this video it's a
three-parter for the Nachman sin gambit
if you do like this series of going more
in depth I know this video it's a little
bit longer but if you have a minute the
entire time thank you guys so much for
watching if there's other openings that
you would like me to cover this in depth
please let me know in the comments below
you can also reach out to me on the
website I have a chat functionality you
can always email me at the chess website
at gmail.com but thank you guys so much
for watching and I'll see you guys in
the next video
you